insulté et frappé alors qu'il
interpellait trois jeunes hommes en
plein camping sauvage c'est ce qu'a subi
francis d'hulst le maire délégué de
portbail petite station balnéaire de la
manche le 6 juillet dernier
il m'a traitée de et qu' il allait
cramer la voiture
ce même individu est arrivé derrière moi
et puis ma m'a balancé deux coups de
poing dans la nuque et sur le haut de
leur île plate
l'élu a déposé une plainte mais à sa
stupéfaction
l'auteur des violences c'est seulement
vu imposer un rappel à la loi et le
dossier a été classé sans suite une
décision du parquet de cherbourg qu'il
déplore c'est pas normal que on puisse
se dire tiens j'ai pas intervenir sur
telle ou telle situation parce que je
risque ma vie il faut absolument que
tous les maires soient protégés l'attak
de francis d'hulst est loin d'être un
cas isolé
depuis le début de l'année 233 maires ou
adjoints ont subi des agressions contre
181 18 l'an dernier sur la même période
selon les chiffres du ministère de
l'intérieur
elles sont en hausse de 14% par rapport
à 2010 9 des violences parfois
récurrentes
pierre-emmanuel béni ancien maire de
saâcy sur marne en ile de france a été
agressé plusieurs fois on a là un bal
je sors de la voiture et la lune
personnes éméchées commencé un peu
insulté la police municipale s'il se
rend compte que je suis maire et à ce
moment là m e shop par le coup il veut
mettre des coups de poing il c'est de
mettre par terre et c est en fait c'est
une agression semble tout lambda
malheureusement pour les élus locaux
mais qui quand vous la recevez est assez
violente psychologiquement j'ai eu droit
à un flot d'insultés comme la police
municipale a commencé à verbaliser des
véhicules qui stationnaient de manière
anarchique sur les trottoirs aux abords
de la gare c'était pendant des mois et
des mois des insultes au quotidien par
mail des menaces etc
une situation qu'il a en partie poussé à
renoncer à se présenter à un nouveau
mandat
face au nombre croissant d'agressions la
loi dite engagement et proximité du 27
décembre 2019 à renforcer la protection
juridique des mères des mesures jugées
aujourd'hui insuffisante par philippe
bas le président les républicains de la
commission des lois du sénat
dans un courrier adressé le 6
dernier au premier ministre jean castex
ils réclament d'aller plus loin que
toutes formes de violence à l'égard des
mères soient sanctionnés de manière
rapide et proportionnée pour le moment
le premier ministre a dénoncé sur les
réseaux sociaux des faits et des
violences inadmissibles en soutien à un
autre maire le 5 juillet dernier
mais les élus restent sans réponse face
à leur demande d'une plus grande fermeté
pourtant leur inquiétude
elle aussi est croissante l'an dernier
jean mathieu michel merde signe un
village du var est mort renversé par une
camionnette dont il voulait verbaliser
les occupants